[Music]
you guys know how we're all
i guess technically considered
millennials yes right
yep did you hear about the two kinds of
millennials like
millennial a millennial b we're like
millennial a which is closer to
groomers generation x oh that's you guys
yeah we're going and then
millennium b is closer to gen z yeah but
then
it's still one group millennials but
there's definitely
yeah two two different ones um well
just to inform you guys we are
officially old
really yes why what is the youngest
millennial now
30 oh i don't know but i'm talking about
gen zers
they are going on tick-tock and [ __ ]
wrecking us
as millennials no way jose we getting
wrecked by gen z
oh no how are they recognized let me see
dude and the boomers reckless too
damn cause like we hate these
millennials and we're like oh no we're
sorry
and then we got the youngins saying they
hate us too so what do we do what do we
do
oh dude we gotta fight back we gotta
fight yeah we gotta go to war
millennials are probably the most [ __ ]
generation though yeah cause we're
[ __ ] to one group and then we're lame
to the other group
but hey just wait for the baby movers to
not get social security that's gonna be
funny
they're gonna be begging for us to work
or when the gen zires are getting called
out by the next gen
who's that taika what's his baby yeah
what's happening what's that
i don't know i don't know what that
means you restart the alphabet it's
jenna yeah
there are six generations i gen
so okay i don't know gen z is it the
next one exclamation point
just follow the keyboard right comma
exclamation point period
colon yeah oh it's called alpha
oh it goes back to the [ __ ] alpha that's
sick it goes greek
and then it's gen
[Laughter]
that'll be super fun what you'd have to
be born to be a generation alpha
2013 i could see the alpha's making a
bunch of betas 20 25.
that sounds right that is taika yeah
just because to rebel against alpha-ism
you have to become a beta
yeah that's funny yeah isaac is totally
igen genzie igen
yeah so gen z are the ones that are
wrecking us
yes it's millennials generation y gen x
why is isaac wrecking us
isaac thinks i'm cool tell him to stop
wrecking this please well that's what i
heard from him
he's wrecking you dude that's what he
said to your face but then when we get
offline he's like what a [ __ ] loser
isaac is that kind of kid right he's
like sweet to your face and he's like
[Music]
the whole ride knows i don't know what
goes beyond what i see so yeah he could
after i see that kid the whole car ride
home he's going
and he doesn't stop this is one constant
stream
but yeah so gen z they're going on tik
tok and
telling us to no longer use
the crying laughing emoji because then
that means you're old for reals
yeah what do they use we'll use that the
rolling one the rolling
we're gonna use it against them what if
you don't even use the emojis
is that cool i don't know that's weird
what about this one where like two
friends do this
two girlfriends do this wait that's an
emoji no but it's just you do it in
even make an pictures dan why dude they
didn't even make that an emergency
that's funny because like a [ __ ] bond
ladies and gentlemen
you say my partner in crime
that's funny my ride or die [ __ ] yeah
you keep embossed on the frame
physically because then your oldest [ __ ]
bart don't use it
the cry face emoji what about this one
like to laugh i like this one i like
that one too though oh the two hands
but the other one or the other thing
that they're really going
hard on is skinny jeans
if you wear skinny jeans you're [ __ ]
old really damn they get their own
are they back to baggy again yeah
they're back to mom jeans
like remember when we were in japan and
then we're like that's probably going to
come here
soon and that was like four years ago
five years ago
yeah like not bell bottoms but like no
bell bottoms are part of it oh when they
show the anchor
uh what's the one when it's like fat but
then you show the ankle flares we saw
them all over japan
what about straight leg is that okay i
don't know the baggy jeans are back
i think that i think like straight cut
jeans yeah like straight here
straight cut top upper crop i'll show
you a tick tock example
what the [ __ ] so it says up here me when
i wear skinny jeans
damn i wish i was swag
if only i was swag
when i wear baggy jeans oh my god what
those look like just regular ass pants
maybe she didn't have baggy jeans that
looked like she
got into mom jeans after that that's
what's happened now mom jeans are in
guys are supposed to wear mom jeans well
i think they're really targeting it for
girls some guys have been wearing mom
jeans for a long time i have to say
i'm glad the baggie looks coming back
[ __ ] my [ __ ]
pants are so uncomfortable sometimes you
know what i actually
i don't think i can i can go back to
that i think i'm stuck with skinny
forever i'm just gonna be old i don't
give a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] boomer
well last time i was hiking and i tried
to put my knee up like this
and then my stomach and my [ __ ] thigh
and everything got caught and i'm all
like why can't we go back to baggy
well there you go it did get pretty
skinny for a minute though
it got like like that was not that was
unacceptable it got it got so skinny
where like
my leg hairs were like like when you
pull up your pants your leg hairs go up
with the jeans yeah and it's like stays
in that position when you take it off
your leg hair it's like the
it just like feels sore the helmet relax
after you take your pants off
yeah that's too tight no skinny just
straight leg that's it yeah i'm not a
fan
at all you know why because when i was
little i actually would wear
like baggier fitting jeans and this one
time i was
at i was with my best friend and she
would go to church i would go with her
to her church and we were sitting
up like in the pews and then so i was
sitting like this and then the girl
behind me she goes
tiffany did you poop your pants and i'm
like
what [ __ ] she was like yeah did you poke
your pants and i'm like
what are you talking about so i look and
i used to have my jeans like
way down like [ __ ] here like this
yeah like really really down and then so
my best friend was like
it looks like you pooped in your pants
so ever since that day i've been [ __ ]
traumatized no
my ass is going to hug my jeans to prove
that there's no poop there's no poop in
there okay
but what made her believe that you
pooped them
oh cause it looked like you had a little
load yeah it looked like i had a load in
my
my butt i understand there's other
symptoms of if someone pooped
that doesn't make sense yeah like what
was she prepared for like asking you
that i think she was gonna wink at her
like was she gonna be like
oh my god i thought so here
yeah you know i was [ __ ] up she was
way older i was like
maybe like maybe she should hear her she
was probably [ __ ] with you
yeah yeah i don't know that seems like a
way to bring someone down
she was like at least she was like
mid-20s at least but she was she knows
nobody's [ __ ]
she was [ __ ] with you damn she
traumatized me and i'm like yeah that
was her objective
because she's got to be stupid as hell
to really believe you [ __ ] yourself yeah
if you really loaded those things up we
would expect moisture
or smells yeah she was [ __ ] with you
like if you if you really pack those
things up i think that that would be
evidence
yeah so then ever since that day i've
been like [ __ ] putting my pants up
and i'm like i'm never sagging again
you gotta get those pads that you go all
the way up and you [ __ ] put it all
the way here and you put the belt like a
1950s boxer
and then you just take a huge [ __ ] in
church oh yeah those are called
high-waisted
those are in too joe high-waisted jeans
you remember the uh like what in the 40s
or something
that's how guys used to wear their pants
like up here yeah and then they had
their little shirts
just in case we gotta improvise see oh
we gotta fight are we
oh you put up your dukes i say it made
their bellies really come out too
yeah oh yeah a little puff do you think
that's attractive though guys
wearing pants that go over their belly
button no
but that was like the thing that our
grandparents did yeah but maybe that was
hot for them
just like how in future generations
seeing
guys in skinny jeans are like repulsive
i don't know oh no it was repulsive at
the time
i was against i was against the whole
time against i have to say
you know what's funny the whole time so
like you know how like we're talking
about like
what what is what makes like a guy a man
you know and so my uncle was telling me
like dad bods he's like man he's like
i couldn't wait to get like a little
belly and a dad
cause that was like manly and i was like
really and then like yeah all the guys i
guess their age were like trying to
achieve that look and i looked over to
my aunt my mom and i was like so
is that what the girls like they're like
nah we dreaded those days
like the guys she's like yeah oh no
no you're like your uncle used to look
so good you know and it is like
they couldn't wait to be a fat [ __ ] it's
like that chick in the matrix she's like
not like this
not like this
[Laughter]
so the last thing here that jen's ears
are attacking millennials for
is the way we part
our hair well i don't even part my hair
yeah i don't even have hair you stupid
[ __ ] that's the correct way
it's more for girls okay so you oh i'm
in a room full of guys there's no other
girl
we can't identify hold on i can put up
my hair
is this a millennial part dad my hair is
long dude across all genders
okay do the side part like this so
that's how millennials
do their hair right like this is how we
do our hair millennial
you look like the the jack on a card on
a poker card when he was moving down the
middle
yeah so now jen's viewers are trying to
get everyone to do a middle part
i want to do a gen z part so here's
another tick tock of a
millennial chick being like oh she says
me a lifelong side carter forcing a
middle part so gen z doesn't know i'm
old
oh my god thank you for [ __ ] inviting
me yes rosa so glad you can make it
your house is so pretty
yeah it's just i might be a boomer or uh
whatever gen z or
or when millennials are but at least i
can sync my [ __ ] audio
[Laughter]
hey who's before boomer uh the depressed
wait so from the great depression what's
the modern way the moderns in the middle
or the models on the side
so the modern is on the middle you know
what's crazy
i started doing this before i found this
[ __ ] out so i was like oh and then
i'm actually so happy about the middle
part because this is the best way for my
hair to fall too late
because i have two [ __ ] um what are
they called
the cowlicks i have two cowlicks on each
side
so for this entire side part trend
that's been the last 15 years
i've always [ __ ] struggled because my
hair can't properly side part so now
that the middle part is back i'm [ __ ]
happy
but tiff why are we trying to be like
them they're so [ __ ] mean yeah i mean
so the cool thing though is the trend
caught up to you you didn't have to do
the trend
you know what i mean yeah you've been
fashion forward you were just late
so late that when fashion made a full
circle
it caught up caught up with me yeah
exactly no because remember like
two-ish years ago i started i've been
wanting to put my hair in the middle
on the outside and then i kept telling i
kept showing casey because i'm like i
kept putting my hair down in the middle
like with the middle part and i'm like
i don't know i feel like i look like
cher like sonny estonian
yeah look 70s for you tony and cher yeah
sony and chair
up in our era partying your hair in the
middle was lame that was like
it was actually like you get you get
beat up for partying here no middle
school yeah
that's like the nerdy way of parting it
just crazy because literally the [ __ ]
beatles
did that yeah and they were the coolest
band of all time at the time
yeah yoko also did you guys ever do
things like this
as a target for violence because you
wanted someone to attack you
i wasn't smart enough to do that so i
would go to shirt come to shirt and i
have like a care bear thing on my
shirt i'm like come on come make fun of
me dude so i could defend myself wow
you really had something to prove huh
yeah back in those days you were bald by
the way
i know i didn't have that hair i should
have done this though this would have
been way smarter
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you